[موسيقى]
الفودكا دائمًا خيار جيد قوي وسلس
ومبهج ، فودكا صافية مبهجة عادة ما تكون مصنوعة
من عنب البطاطس أو القمح ، يقوم رجل واحد
بعمل الأشياء بشكل مختلف إنه يصنع
الفودكا من نعم سمعت أن
الخروف المناسب نحن في خليج البتولا في تسمانيا
أستراليا قبل 16 عامًا عائلتي
صنعت ليلًا جبنة الخراف
من الصفر ، كنت أتعب من مجرد
القيام بأشياء من أنواع الجبن ، لذا
توصلت إلى فكرة تقطير
المادة كيف باستخدامها بعيدًا ، فلماذا يعد
جزءًا أساسيًا من صناعة الجبن
وفي كثير من الحالات يتم إخمادها  الصرف
والهدر ، لقد اكتشفت طريقة لتحويل
ذلك إلى منتج يجعل الفودكا من
مصل اللبن أمرًا غير معتاد تمامًا ، كانت هناك
محاولتان ناجحتان ولكن
لم يصنع أحد من قبل فودكا zwei حتى
جاء ريان استغرق الأمر منه حوالي
مئات المحاولات على مدار
عام لكنه وصل إلى هناك ، لذا الخطوة الأولى
نحلب الخروف ثم نعطيها
لمصنع الجبن الخاص بنا الذي يحولها بعد ذلك إلى
جبن ثم الطريق هو ما تبقى
على
الطبق.  الحلقة الثانية أمسكت بهذه الطريقة ثم
أضفت الإنزيمات التي تخمرها إلى الكحول ، ما ينتج عنه الكحول
أساسًا هو
سكر أساسي وسكر أساسي هو
اللاكتوز ، الخطوة الثالثة ، أحضر هذا الكحول
وقم بتقطيره مرتين في روح منتهية
والخطوة الرابعة لقد عمرت الروح من
أجل  أربعة أشهر الخطوة الخامسة نقوم
بالفعل بطلاء الزجاجة بالكامل يدويًا ، لذلك
نرش الأسود ثم نكتب باليد بحيث
تكون كل زجاجة فريدة من نوعها ، بداية
من حلب الأغنام
وصولاً إلى تعبئة المنتج ، سيستغرق الأمر
خمسة أشهر على الأقل.  ستشتم الكثير
من الحلاوة القادمة من
الحليب ، وبعد ذلك عندما تشربها
ستكون كريمية حقًا على الحنك
وتقريباً نوعاً ما حليبي أنهى واحدة
من أكبر الجوائز التي فزنا بها كانت
أفضل فودكا في العالم والتي كانت ضخمة  بالنسبة لنا
في الفودكا ، ليست نهاية
تجارب تقطير النبيذ ، فقد غامر أيضًا
بالجن والآن ليخبرنا كيف شربته ، لذا تعامل معه
حقًا على غرار الويسكي اللطيف
والأنيق حتى مع  مع عدم وجود جليد ، هذا رائع
حقًا ، إنه رائع حقًا ، إنه رائع حقًا ،
جميل جدًا ، حلم جيد جدًا ،
إنه بالتأكيد جميل
للحنك
[موسيقى]